[Musique]
c'est un haut dirigeant d'une formation
politique majeure du pays que scadi
accueille ce matin bonjour Daniel
marieinthe bonjour monsieur von
secrétaire national à l'organisation du
mouvement indépendantiste Martinique et
dans moins le 15 jours Daniel Marie
Saint il y aura le premier tour des
législatives dites-nous est-ce que ce
scrutin divise au sein de votre
formation politique non il mobilise au
contraire toute la Martinique connait
votre Fran parler connaî votre franchise
Daniel Marie sain votre capacité
d'analyse votre militantisme avec le
cœur dites-nous quels sont les noms que
vous Daniel Marie saintemur rroir sortir
du du vote les et 17 juin le premier et
ds le premier tour Jean-Philippe Nil qui
est le candidat investi par le MIM nous
avons également n portons notre soutien
total à francisque Carol sur Fort de
France sur les deux autres
circonscriptions il y a pas eu je suis
très frein de consensus au sein du MIM
ilit le président Alfred mariejanne et
moi-même nous soutenons Fabrice Dom le
creatlantique il n pas pas pris de
position pour le nord nous attendons le
deè tour et pourquoi pourquoi justement
ce fait que dans ces deux
circonscriptions les choses n'ont pas
été plus tranché pourquoi on a
l'impression que le MIM vole brusquement
en éclat non il vole pas en éclat il y a
un débat à l'intérieur je suis
secrétaire l'organisation chargée de la
cohésion je rapporte à l'extérieur du M
sur les médias les positions lorsque
nous sommes arrivés à des consensus ou
lorsque nous sommes pas arrivés à des
consensus nous le disons et le président
Marie Jeanne dans nombreuses interv tion
a laisser la liberté la liberté aux
membres du MIM pour le premier tour
ouais dan max vous travaillez au jour le
jour avec des hommes comme Miguel
laaventure Francis Caro ainsi que Marie
France t c'est l'exemple de cette
circonscription de Fort de- France
comment établir un choix pour ceux qui
coram ont porté leur voix sur le grand
semblé pas pay en CH vous AZ demandé à
ses électeur de choisir entre trois
personnes
qui Ben qui travaillent ensemble si vous
suivez bien l'actualité politique oui le
MIM que vous m'interpellez en tant que
MIM a fait un accord politique profond
au ni ce que nous appelons l'alliance
des patriotes en 2004 avec le CNCP ça
s'est élargi par la suite des 2008 avec
le palima don Francis Carol est le
président donc nor alliance patriotique
ensuite en 2009 nous avons élargi à une
alliance du camp de la responsabilité le
RDM Martinique écologie le PCM et puis à
l'occasion de la des élections de la CTM
nous avons fait un contrat de gestion
c'est pas la même chose que la lance
politique c'est un contrat pour gérer
l'impression que ça été compris je veux
dire et c'est très clairement ah je sais
pas comment vous l'avez interprété c'est
dit mais est-ce que c'est compris par il
y a un texte que nous avons rendu public
qui était signé par tous les partenaires
qui disait que chacun des partis gardait
euh leur principes le autonomie et
cetera dans les élections où il s'agit
d'envoyer des représentants du peuple
peup à Paris nous avons admis qu'il y
avait la liberté politique h le premier
tour permet à chacun d'abord de mesurer
leur impact dans l'opinion publique de
permettre aux électeurs de faire un
choix c'est très démocratique h dans le
je ne vois je ne vois aucune
contradiction avec le fait que nous
ayons fait un accord de gestion qui
n'incluait pas les législatif si jamais
vous deviez voter dans le Nord vous
ariez voté pour qui il y a de mon
plaisir ou je ne vote pas dans le Nord
je vote au lentin je vous ai dit je vé
Fabrice Duom euh j'ai rencontré certains
militants du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquet qui bon ils ont bien entendu
votre discours Daniel marissette mais
quand même il se disait que le MIM avait
la possibilité aurait dû avoir cette
capacité d'envoyer quatre candidats
estampiller 100 % patriote 100 % Alfred
mariejeune oui il y avait donc des
militants je le confesse qui avait cette
ambition le président mariean pas ils
sont déçus ils sont déçus vous
l'entendez cette déception quand même
non non non il on discute le M débat
notre débat Inter est très int nous
sommes tous des fortes personnalités
nous ne sommes pas arrivés à un
consensus dans le N donc les électeurs
vont choisir et nous verront au deuxème
tour ce qu'il a eu de faire Daniel Marie
comment expliquer comment expliquer
l'absence d'Alfred mariejeanne au côté
de Jean-Philippe nillord durant la
campagne Chabin qui s malgard des match
football passé ptit bolomlan Chabin qui
t transmettent en flambau qui t' obligé
à les remamasser parce que tibouak
couillon
oui oui oui ou ramassz vos propos dans
les
Canau dans les canivaux par exemple de
certainunionu il faut être il faut être
présent il faut être présent j'invite je
d'ailleurs invité la presse lorsque nous
faisons no réunions monsieur le public
bon nous avons pas toujours l'honneur de
vous accueillir mais en tout cas ça vous
arrive de temps en temps mais je peux
vous dire qu'Alfred mariejeanne soutient
tout à fait la candidature de
Jean-Philippe du Nord dans le sud il a
réaffirmé dans le mot du MIM ce weekend
dernier donc il y a des personnes qui
veulent démolir le MIM et qui ben les
gens de l'extérieur de l'extérieur de
l'extérieur du MIM mais parce que parce
nous avons connu d'autres bourasques oui
Jean Philippe n est le candidat
totalement investi par le M mais je
profite de votre antenne pour raeler
tous les militants en particulier dans
la circonsftion du Sud à se grouper
comme un seul homme ou une seule femme
derè Jean-Philippe il doit gagner dès le
premier tour je vous pose la question
pourquoi Daniel mariein tout simplement
parce que euh vous écoutez tout ce qui
se passe sur la scène politique
martinicaaise française ou peut-être
même ailleurs mais lorsqu'on entend dans
d'autres formations politiques que un
des siens est attaqué euh ben pourquoi
les autres membres de cette famille
politique ne monte pas au Crino avec la
même virulence que l'attaque porté euh
pour défendre son son Poulin en tout cas
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
là ouais vous continuez à colporter des
propos question je vous dis que tout le
MIM tout le MIM est rassemblé der
Jean-Philippe Nilor je le répète encore
ouais et il faut pas croire tous les
Ragot on essaie de démolir le MIM le MIM
n'a
pas de crê à avir hm hm mais éoute on
aurait aimé vous voir faire davantage
corps avec Jean-Philippe Nilor face aux
rumeurs incessantes concernant
l'ascenseur concernant son absenté ou
même la faiblesse prétendue je dis bien
prétendu son de députz fait des
investigations sur les propos que vous
rapportez là c'est lamentable ça h bien
il y a il y a quelqu'un qui souhaite
démolir Jean-Philippe Nilor il est venu
la cibleattaque je sais pas quel pour
pour qui ce sont des faits qui sont
entrés de pleinpli dans la campagne vous
êtes d'accord avec moi non ce sont pas
des faits oh ce sont fait monsieur ce
sont des racontards ouis je pense je
pensais au contraire qu'on aurait dû
faire un bilan du député qui a beaucoup
travaillé oui qui a beaucoup travaillé
et c'est ce qui il mérite d'être
reconduit l'absentéisme ce sont des
rumeurs ce sont
des sa présence à l'assemblée nationale
n
pasb doit être présent à 100 %e la
question puis que c'est c'est c'est sur
ça que le candidat est 100 %
patriote est attaqué aujourd'hui durant
la campagne oui oui c'est peut-être par
les adversaires donc vous faites le
relais oui mais en même temps il est le
député qui recevait le plus de sa
permanence quand en Martinique parce que
les électeurs ont besoin de contact et
ça c'est suffisment expqu et ça c'est
suffisamment
expliqué je crois que vous vous préférez
donner
le je vous dis mais c'est ce qu'il fait
depuis un an il fait son bilan dans
toutes les quartiers du Sud c'est
pourquoi on le voit un peu moins dans
les médiia partout mais il est sur le
terrain et c'est la recommandation que
je lui toujours faite d'être présent
enant peup h en dant peup au sein du
peuple dans tous les quartiers pour
faire son bilan depuis un an il fait son
bilan il présente avec diap C mais
évidemment la presse ne s'intéresse pas
à ça la presse s'intéresse au petit
cancan à la mousse qui est au auudessus
de l'eau c'est pas ça c'est pas ça qui
est important l'important
c'est c'est un député sérieux
travailleur mais nous souhaitons
également que notre patriote à Fort de
France oui
c'est la Fort de France c'est la mer des
batailles oui c'est la mer des batailles
Fort de France oui c'est pour cela qu'
il y a l'unanimité derrière Francis
Carol je tenais ce matin à l'indiquer
fortement que tous nos militants tous
nos sympathisants tous les patriotes
tous ceux qui sont partisan
véritablement du camp de la
responsabilité doit faire cor avec
Francis Carol parce qu'il faut mettre
fin à ce qui se passe à for- de France
Daniel Marie
sain concernant cette participation
législative se pose aussi aussi la
question du financement des partis
derrière avec d'autres candidats je le
rappelle estampillé 100 % MIM est-ce que
quelque part ça n'aurait pas pu assurer
un peu plus l'avenir financier de votre
formation politique vous croyez vraiment
que c'est pour cela que nous faons je
vous pose la question monsieur ce n'est
pas le premier souci ce n'est pas le
premier souci ce n'est pas notre premier
souci notre premier souci d'abord n nous
sommes battus pour qu'il y ait une
collectivité unique de Martinique grâce
au
c'est un des notes Alfred Marie qui a la
tête nous devons réussir cela il a
choisi donc il faut moi j'ai choisi
également faut transformer les avec et
nous avons besoin parce que nous sommes
encore sous tutelle de l'État français
nous avons besoin de porte-parole qui a
à Paris pour négocier prolonger la lutte
que nous faisons ici face au
gouvernement parce qu'il faut encore
mener des négociations c'est pour cela
que nous avons besoin des délégués du
peuple c'estàdire des députés au sens
étyologique qui sont qui auront cette
mission de prolonger le travail que nous
faisons la CTM c'est ça pour nous le
sens du député nous ne participons pas
aux élections législatives françaises
simplement pour ramasser de l'argent ça
c'esti aussi le MIM doit compter sur les
cotisations de ses membres Daniel
mariein après ces élections législatives
comment ça se passera au niveau du même
du MIM puisque vous êtes secrétaire
national à l'organisation est-ce qu'il y
aura un congrès est-ce qu'il aura de un
renouvellement du comité national est-ce
que vous y pensez déjà ou bien c'est
quelque chose qu'on verra après non non
non après les élections d'abord les
choses vont reprendre leur place oui nos
réunions vont recommencer normalement
parce que nous avons libéré nos
militants pour partir en campagne ben
dès le 18 c'est dire au lendemain des
élections pour la Martinique ben les
choses reprendnent local c'est vrai nous
sommes en train de vivre une
passation une passation de témoin à
l'intérieur du MIM il y a une génération
qui a commencé au début des années 70
qui a accompli sa mission et puis il y a
une relève qui est assurée Jean-Philippe
Nilor on fait partie d'autres aurinella
là qui sont les jeunes les les les
jeunes qui nous ont rejoint et bien
auront à prendre le relais pour
continuer et aller plus loin dans la
lutte pour la responsabilité c'est ça
laavenir lu même merci Daniel Marie c un
rappel secrétaire national à
l'organisation du bour indépendantiste
Martinique merci d'avoir été dans bonne
journée